hey guys how's it going welcome to my
kitchen I'm Justine today we're gonna be
making some earth today cookies Earth
Day is this week so to celebrate I
googled Earth Day desserts and this one
popped up and I thought wow I think I
can possibly do this so let's start with
the sugar cookie recipe that smelly
items here food coloring which is most
important I no longer have a 1 cup
measuring cup because it's in the dog
food bring it up in a 375 I was doing
350 holy moly skewed it's cute dog to
deter Buddha I met him at the club that
was ok let's see 1 cup of butter
softened 1 and 1/2 cups of white sugar
holy moly
1/2 cup 1/2 cup 1 and 1/2 cups gradually
blend the dry ingredients
neum oh crap I do this every time I mean
to soften the butter and I basically
boil it oops that is a whole chunk
stir
so because I'm not sure how this is
going to work I read somewhere online
that it's you need to use gel food
coloring or something and I don't have
that so I'm basically just gonna hope
for the best and hope this works so this
is going to be my water of my earth
I absolutely have no idea if this is
going to work
let's do a little faster cool finish
good through the pasture Oh God
beat in the egg and vanilla beat it beat
it don't you want to be defeated die
one teaspoon vanilla extract ah smells
nice oh that was definitely not a
teaspoon that was a lot more than a
teaspoon oh gosh
why are you not going on there gradually
blend the dry ingredients 2 and 3/4 cups
3/4 cup so 3/4 cup yeah half a cup
and about three books this looks good
I think it's not that blue though
Matthew or dogs there's no one there's
actually no one here I promise you if
there is oh god we've got a problem
let's see if we can make us a little
more blue a little bit faster
that's good yea-ah proud of my work I'm
gonna take this listen here it was
recommended to chill your doe home alone
while that chills I'm going to make my
green
Oh God two backs holy moly
alright got our green we've got our blue
this is the mess clean up like I've
never sure if you're supposed to spray
your pants this stuff doesn't stick but
I'm gonna spray cuz I don't want it to
sit this blue does not look good
probably should take off my rings that's
not rolling very good too much flour
okay into the oven we go
okay the bookings are done oh god
they're starting to crisp a little bit
let's put them on this cooling rack the
earth looks beautiful
here's cookies oops so they turned out
okay I feel like this might be the earth
if we don't recycle the blue is
definitely not too blue and the green is
really not that green the let's taste it
mmm it's actually really good why we're
really long it's a nice taste in grey so
much for watching let me know in the
comments below what you'd like me to
attempt to cook next these are fake
cookies actually weren't too bad happy
Earth Day I love you guys
I'll see you soon oh right oh right
happy tech Tuesday so recorded this
previous video about the iPhone last
night but this morning Apple launched
some new MacBooks